es geht weniger aus Ostfranken und auch
mit der schaffe mit der Fitmacher dass
ich laber von Manschetten Noten
für illegale
schwitzen
Pflanzschale vocc-t wie genau
funktioniert das wie viel Geld kriegt
mit aberwitzigen immer um kraxi was
macht mit dem man schüttet wer ist das
und was was passiert wenn du jahrelang
sobre Keller
[Musik]
antworte Forchheim alte Station
Langenthal im Kanton Bern die wilde
Seite contra ich bin immer wieder
kritisiert und
[Applaus]
Schwede gelabert dass mir unter Druck
sie dass mir sauber verschwitzt unsere
weiß wo es sicher doch logisch dass kein
Mensch mit acht Tage pro Tag Calabro
oder das geht gar nicht und wenn du
irgendjemand bist ruf ich wieder neue
Schuhe oder Regenjacke
/ kulinarisches Chaussee 8 Jahre
schwitzt ja für Kollegen und Bekannte
und
7 Raum eingebrochen eingeschätzt
Solothurn
zeige Geld verdiene besuchen Sie das
suche CDs und Internet-Seiten die
Familie shyshko wenn der Vater im Iran
verfolgt werde das Huntington Behörde
aber nicht glaubt und Iris Asylgesuch
abgelehnt zu schaffen in Iran und
Behörde sie aber nöd will Schwyz Kasse
Rückübernahmeabkommen mit mir anhand
[Musik]
Honig Aufguss wysoka olesno
mysteriöse mini Ambulatorium Fußballclub
da aus Anita und wenn ich dafür ja womit
sie
vergangen ist die Gang zurück das geht
nicht das geht gar nicht.
Ich knuddel knutsch Eventim in Abyss
möschwitz verlautet Realität sieht aber
anders twos Knaller geht aber
Luciano tief grün sind sehr
unterschiedlich
rufst du jetzt rufe und mich auch nicht
hier bliebe ich nächstes mit euch da
ziehe ich weg war für dich auch nachts
Zug in Zürich
im Gefängnis Busse von Polizei 2000
Frankenbach und ich habe gar nicht
gemacht ich bin nur in unsere Zentrum
und bleiben immer bestelle kann ich weiß
wegen dass
du musst diese Strafe bezahlen von
Polizei wann muss anni 2000 Franke Ich
muss in Gefängnis zwei Monate und acht
Tage bleiben hast du manchmal Angst
ich bin immer jeden Tag jeden Tag
vor was hast du Angst vor
also jetzt machen
ödemzentrum sag mir so
[Musik]
Checker Tobi das Fußballtraining
[Applaus]
andere deine Sicherheit zu dir hoch
gehen und so Kühlschrank bei dir diese
Zimmer okay
Dusche
[Musik]
ich liebe wenn ihr damit raumprobe seid
ihr heute Helme Liquid Center
und 2700 Strafe bekommen wo Zahlen dass
du warst im Gefängnis hast du acht
Monate schwanger warst ja fast neun
Monate schwanger
wieso
wegen dir sein
scheiße weißt du ich bin noch jung
und wegen dass ich habe viele Probleme
ich merke tongues begleitet jeden Tag
es sind jetzt schon paar Tage vergangen
sind mehr in Zürich die Interviews
geführt und ich merke Ziele mich nicht
in Ruhe und zwar ist für mich
unvorstellbar sie stehen wo jeder Kanton
der Person Zeitung Mursch genau an dem
Ort wohnen oder in der Unterkunft musst
du sie da muss jeder durch
sind und die
zweite Musik Franken sie das einzige
Stück seid und das will ich genaueres
letzte Woche am Interview hast du
erzählt von diesen Bussen die du kriegst
von der Polizei könntest du mir
vielleicht ein Foto einer solchen Buße
schicken
grundsätzlich ich esse so werde der
Nothilfe lebt und in der
Polizeikontrolle Hund der Hund jedesmal
verzeigt werden Bagger rechtswidrige
movietown das geht die Geldstrafe und
die Wiederholungsfall hat bis 1 Jahr
Gefängnis bitte dort wie geht's aber
kantonal große Unterschied nur wenig
Controller
macht das nach meiner Recherche Kanton
Zürich Zürich
Strafbefehl und dir bestätigen was das
erzählt hat
ebertwiese wieso Claudi Strafbefehl
ausgestellt werden doch das ist nicht
immer so einfach Ostwind
Sicherheitsdirektion verwies mich an
Staatsanwaltschaft und
Staatsanwaltschaft seid für Controller
ziggyd Kantonspolizei zuständig und dir
wiederum antwortet sie machen Kontrolle
sowohl auf Eigeninitiative im Auftrag
für andere Behörde grundsätzlich Polizei
aber nur dafür zuständig für die
Straftat Audi Zustand stellt
der Strafbefehl
für die Seite ist Fußball eine Feder
weniger auf 80 nicht im Auto obwohl das
nicht vorgesehen seht ihr seid in die
Zukunft Dieter schwyz.ch für andere Idee
Nothilfe Sätze
das ist für die meiste der Not hilft die
einzige Chance darin jetzt Bieber
Kriterien für das sind aber strikt 2020
kann nur 105 erwacht negiup Quiz die dir
süße wieso in Offenthal Status behoben
in Steffisburg Narbe tun, tibetische
Familiensache sie labert in der ganz
andere Situation nur die medizentrum
sondern in der Evonik bekannte Familie
begleitet mich auf dem Zug
wenn wir in der in der
Asylzentrum wohnt die sagen was kochst
du das weg die öffnen die Fenster
Fenster und so hier ist freiwillig was
wir wollen wir dürfen gucken wir auch
die Heiden Freiheit oder in Zentrum wir
müssen immer zu kommen mit du darfst
nichts her gehen hier nicht aber hier
freiwillig wir haben zwei verschiedene
Schlafzimmer
schlafen mit uns
ja immer wie ist das für die Kinder
wir kommen eine Familie rausgenommen so
wir haben sehr schlechte Erfahrung im
Zentrum ja
RLS in Germany
ja herzlichen Dank für den Tee bitte
schön für die Gastfreundschaft
und die Familie sind sehr dankbar dass
sie sowohl aber es ist noch die alte
Meister
Unterkunft
[Musik]
sagen dass man Masern Familiensystem
einmal nicht gestern morgen nur gucken
von Kinder und ertrinken Wasser oder
etwas Tee ohne Brot manchmal brutal
Kinder auch manchmal wenn sie brauchte
essen oder trinken wir gehen nicht
passieren wegen er vergessen ja wir
machen so ist das Kind den Hunger du
gehst ja
wissen
[Musik]
starte sprachlos und
so
und jetzt Hunger
Hunger Hunger
zu Aldi Schicht also watching me crazy
anrufen
[Musik]
oder stand Station oder Deutschland
Station
Notruf bissig nothilfezentrum Flüeli
will
ich
meine es für mich aus alte Städte wie
krass ich die Berge du überhaupt und ich
finds mega nice aber
Wunsch und wird Wecker
stellen
wo ich warte warte dann in Tabelle steht
keine Post mehr ja und dann zu Fuß ja
bis hier
20 Uhr
ist sehr schwierig trotzdem
will sie denn sie hat gar nicht dann
weißt Du hier angekommen bist das erste
Mal er ist
keine Hoffnung
und in den Keller und dann wären wir
kommen Milch
Joghurt ja eine Woche willhaben Joghurt
eine Woche nein eine Woche will bekommen
pro Person 6 Stück Eier und keine
Joghurt und nächste Woche will bekommen
Joghurt keine Eier und heute ist deine
Joghurt hoch oder eine Woche
öffnen mit Bussi oder Rechnung weil ich
habe keine Geld ich kann ich billig
kaufen das Volume konnte sein Zimmer in
Langweid oder in Groß oder in Kur oder
in andere Stadt aber nicht hier aber ich
weiß nicht dass ich dort hat extra so
gemacht bis die Leute z.b. freiwillig
gehen weg bis um 3 Uhr bis um 4 Uhr am
Morgen wir sind wach weil das geht nicht
wir können nicht schlafen weil wenn man
hat keine zu tun keine zum Babys zu
machen kann man nicht z.b. immer
pünktlich schlafen und Bundes aufstehen
ich gehe es immer fünf Minuten nach fünf
Minuten kommen wieder hier windig oder
Wolken oder Regen oder bist wieder
traurig wieder oben wieder unten wieder
oben wie du unten das ist das Tag lauf
zu das Leben hier oben ist wie soll ich
sagen das ist das ist nicht Leben
wirklich
Sommerzeit sieht auch schon aber im
Winter wie auch niemand geht unter nicht
schwierig weil wir haben nicht gute
Schuhe Winterschuhe
und das braucht eine gute Winterschuhe
ja sieht auch sehr gut schau bisschen
Bad Ragaz findest du das noch schön ja
ist schon aber wenn man hat
Möglichkeit
ok vielleicht wurde sie ist schon aber
für mich nein das ist nicht schön ist
immer gleichen schwierig weiß wie
schätzt du dir deine Zukunft vor ich
sage nicht ich brauche eine Luxusleben
oder eine Lamborghini oder so nein dass
ich will das nicht ich will nur eine
Arbeitsbewilligung ich baue meine Leben
selber
Ergebnisse werden für Liebe und der Hund
Futterneid Wiki bei Geld fürs Postauto
geht's ja kein einzigen Verein
organisierte zwei Wochen im Tal und
sollte Nothilfe beziehende Danz Postauto
damit er mal vorüber wegrennt nur
überall Ideen womit line zur steht immer
wieder mal bis er Möglichkeit ich bin
schwierig es hier meine Noten zum
Schluss Siegen wie er
politische frag deine mega finden kannst
wird oder
so
herzhaft
Klappe zu portiert werden ohne Zukunft
ohne Wind
und ich bin schwierigen eine Konklusion
sie aber was ich finden kann ich sage
schick mir das Krasnici
und ich bin am Schluss nach Drachen ganz
kurz sagen es ist mega schwierig sie
manche rufst
Repeater Nothilfe Fotokamera trachtet
und ich bin voll dankbar für die das
gemacht haben ich weiß ja
wie muss ich da bloß stellt er ja wenn
du Fragen hast zur Not hilft hast mir
Kommentar ist megageil Fundorte